Ryan Chaffey is our champion I mentioned
two of our players have done me you've
done me in college I wouldn't put it
that way Alex but I I was in because I
didn't I didn't play you in the games
that we played is what I meant by that
oh okay I'm a dress designer my fitting
model is out and my deadline is Drawing
Near would you be willing to get into my
dress
baby I'll be willing to get in your
dress your pants
fine thank you what's your story well I
I'm in young girls pants I Manufacturing
next you are one handsome guy whoa I
don't normally like to fly but I am
changing my mind listen we don't have
much time so we want to play okay I'm
ready I'm ready to play anytime too Max
all right you know the rules you can
come fly okay you don't get them like
this that often all right the childhood
prank known as a wet willy involves
putting a wet finger in someone's what
anywhere you want to put it Max all
right
it's pathetic it's just I'm an old horny
woman all right
that was the most infantile suggestion
you made to your wife on your first date
Joe
why don't you eat something all right
Patty says the most infantile suggestion
was that uh that she shouldn't be so
close-minded I should be loser you know
you were loose enough that night
[Applause]
this term for a long-handled gardening
tool can also mean an immoral pleasure
Seeker okay what's a hoe no
whoa whoa
whoa
they teach you that in school in Utah
huh L what's a rake a rake is right how
long will your husband say his inseam is
Nina
seven inches seven inches
name a number that most men exaggerate
100
[Applause]
.
I've been told I can crack walnuts with
my thighs
strongest part of your body
I really hope it's my walnuts but
prayed for snow on her wedding day yes I
did it was 32 degrees and no snow on my
wedding day but I had eight inches on
the honeymoon
something that has to warm up before you
use it sir how about your wife
[Applause]
myself uh how's the game these days well
I'm real I'm real straight but not real
long you need somebody for tattoos and
piercings yeah how many do you currently
have of each well I have two tattoos and
one piercing and I want two more
if Andy yearns for Brenda and Brenda
cares about Charlene who Pines for Andy
the three of them form one of these
Cara what is that threesome
um
Roger what is a love triangle yes that's
it
Cara has obviously had much more
experience than
most of the electricity in our home
flows from the blank to the what from
the plug to the vibrator
something besides soap and a towel that
people take with them to the bath
a duck an occupation that uses it
an occasion for which you stayed up all
night god
um
lost my virginity
foreign
you think about it the police
commissioner said I think Batman and
Robin are queer
[Applause]
didn't you know the moment I got my
Robin outfit a rumor like that Wichita
will humming help your tennis game
or why not it takes your mind off your
balls or something
your husband says the last thing he
loaded
Pam
me
foreign
you're watching balls go back and forth
at speeds of up to 160 miles an hour in
what sport
John jogging
thank you so much for letting me sit
next to the beautiful Kathie Lee my
pleasure hey Kathy Lee no Regis and I
have a lot in common we both broke up
with our beaches this year
[Applause]
you're only encouraging me baby
prices 22 inches chest 57 weighs 33 size
29
what do we have in common you get
smaller as you go down okay
foreign
[Applause]
mentioned in many love songs
uh I'm gonna go for the breasts
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
give me a slang name for policeman
dick
dick
due to its sultry late night programming
viewers have given a particular cable
network with nickname
HB orgasm independent filth Channel
skidamax
screw time
Tammy I am so sorry I really I am not
that kind of a girl well actually I
think my parents would be proud to know
I have no idea ah so I'm gonna ask the
audience no problem Oh you think they
would definitely know us yes Brandon
needs your help
on your keypads vote now
[Music]
69 percent
foreign
[Applause]
we're gonna go with a hot dog sausage
like a wiener
[Laughter]
you need to stop talking
what will your husband says the one
thing he absolutely forbids you to put
on his wiener
Ben Gay
other than popcorn what is your favorite
thing to nibble on at the movies Steve
I'm gonna get shot oh
her boobs I don't know
name something a teenage boy can do for
hours at a time
masturbate
we welcome you and ask you to tell us
about yourself
I live in Orange County
I'm [ __ ] I mean retired
the bill Sergeant has its drawbacks
every time we make love he expects me
too clean his weapon
[Applause]
specific part of the body that women try
to accentuate
favorite rest
[Applause]
one C
there we go again you have sixteen
hundred dollars six hundred okay
no Lisa
650. M yeah there you go and uh
what do we have a street car Named
Desire yeah that's it
650 will make it a thousand and although
you got the right answer I'd rather see
Kevin's play
that's just me